what if Joker ends up killing Bruce
Wayne Manor what if it's actually in
Arthur flex mind this is rogue theory
today we're finding out how we got these
scars I have my attackers here we got
Erik Bosse good we got our friend Chris
cope hello stand-up comedian - Tina Amon
Conan might have seen him in Gainesville
Florida
welcome back welcome back welcome back
yeah guys on this episode we're gonna
get into some rogue theories about it
Chapter two but first we got to talk
about this apparently this surprising
fact that the Joker movies must be
really good and turns out he's got a
really great run Tomatoes score but
there is a question about whether or not
it's gonna have any sequels or if it's
gonna play a role in the broader DC
extended universe or not so that's what
I want to get into is how is this film
going to end in a way that either
connects to it the current universe
doesn't connect to it and maybe start
its own thing or anything else that you
guys want to go rogue on but basically
the Joker movie how does it end and what
does it begin well correct me if I'm
wrong but they've already said that it's
not part of the DC EU right but but the
Batman might also not be part of the DC
you and so they could be starting back
dooring into a new DC you of some sort
yeah DC black has some people are
calling it that's what Todd Phillips
wanted it to be like DC black yeah well
none of us have seen the movie yes none
of the four of us that none of us read
top three rogue theories alright whoa
okay I'm gonna get into mind here's what
I think I think we might be looking at a
situation where what if the Joker like
not only just like survives this but
like he triumphs what if this is truly
the not just a Joker's origin story but
his victory story and we see
a version of Gotham where the villains
are really people like Thomas Wayne the
elites these greedy jerks who think they
know how to run a city and it's said it
turns into this else world style
universe where the Joker is basically
running the show he's yeah it's his city
it turns into like the Narrows it turns
into basically Arkham Asylum
I think that just as a pure villain
character study I'm super excited for
this movie and I love your theory yeah I
mean we know that like Todd Phillips is
pulling from the King of Comedy from
taxi driver and those movies can ended
with this antihero validated as kind of
a weird heroic figure so I would love to
see that but I'm gonna throw another
rogue twist at you guys what if this
whole reality where the Joker is running
Gotham and it's his he's a gangster in
chief what if it's actually in Arthur
flex mind asylum and this is what's in
his brain it's his own little reality
that I agree I disagree I would love
that so much like take it full Birdman
where we don't know what's really all in
it especially what I like about that is
that it not from the beginning right
maybe this is the story but it branches
out to like and then suddenly he's doing
that cocky walk that he does in the
trailer and now he's got followers and
whatnot and then he wins and people
throw him on their shoulders and that's
the part that I realized oh no he lost
very severe he's telling us the story as
he remembers it then it can totally try
to figure out Chris hates it why I think
I honestly I think the way the trailer
sets it up for me like he might be
trying to martyr himself mm-hmm and then
you see the scene where they have a de
masks on
he inspires an entire city and I think
it also makes place your your thought of
it BQ becomes the hero in a lot of ways
and a lot of times heroes are martyred
yeah yeah so okay well so then let's
wrap up Erik's theory is essentially he
he wins it could be all in his mind yeah
or maybe we don't know that we're left
guessing in the same way that like the
Joker's in Alan Moore quote in The
Killing Joke he wants his backstory to
be most
choice so we make have the multiple
choice option of what we think is
reality is this is the realistic take
this is which is the him him winning no
just the movie in general it's the
realistic yeah yeah it's just it's gonna
it's gonna be more grounded I like the
idea that it has a it has an origin well
couldn't go into into your theory it's
killed at the end because it makes sense
he's a weaker he's in trailer boys in
the trailers I'm long I'm going off this
three minutes of the character but he
seems weak I mean clearly that's how
he's supposed to be portrayed I think he
wants to be Marty he wants to be he
doesn't have the shoulders to carry the
burden and I just think he just ends up
dying somehow and then that vid the city
I'm gonna make you take a stance here do
you think he designs it for his death or
you also said he's weak he just ends up
dying and other people turn him into a
martyr apart
and he collapses and people attribute
meaning to what he stood for later
they're making Gotham seem as realistic
place as possible correct politicians
but corrupt you know but wouldn't it be
Thomas Waynes a jerk yeah be so cool to
see himself like to see Arthur Fleck
make himself into the sacrificial figure
then then maybe inspires the Joker of
the comic books that were more
accustomed yeah so right so he he
becomes just this he they sacrifice him
he maybe it starts as lowly Occupy Wall
Street kind of movement but if there's a
death there was no Occupy Wall Street is
not considered a successful movement but
had there been some central figure of it
that was the face of it and then that
person were killed or something I think
yeah someone dies you like oh this is
for someone so then it actually is like
a successful Occupy Wall Street they
bring down the fat cats the Thomas
Waynes you know those greedy doctors
exactly and then inspire a wave of
copycats are we talking Jared Leto's
maybe and and like he could be connected
the Joker right exactly what place in
and it takes place in 1981 I believe
right so if he has created essentially
he's the martyr and a martyr sparks a
religion a ruler's movement of some sort
then he makes followers so are we
thinking that could even because that I
still want to know is this kind of set
up to maybe connect to Robert Pattinson
I think I think this just makes its
point throw in an issue with why it
might not just be a one-off there was
recently an interview with Robert
Pattinson Pattinson and he said
something about Joaquin Phoenix and they
had to remove it I'm sorry you have to
take that out that could be a spoiler
like spoiler energy to it we don't know
what it was comment redacted Imola
report that interview when Robert
Pattinson said that that he hadn't yet
seen the Joker movie so it couldn't be a
spoiler for the Joker movie so you throw
out the phrase I'm excited to get to
work with this guy well it's the same
thing as like we put half we have to put
spoiler warnings at the top of our
videos for things we haven't seen yet
just in case we accidentally say some of
them might end up happening so what if
it's like I'd love to fight him one day
or I think I can take him and that it's
because that's nice cross-promotion yeah
so I mean realistically he probably said
something like I'm really excited to
work with Joaquin Phoenix and then we
were like also it's been a while but
there was a rumor that Robert Pattinson
and Matt Reed's the Batman takes place
in the 90s which is only shortly after
the movement yeah give this moment
everybody to matriculate into the crime
force that is you know the sweeping
across Gotham the Joker was yeah still
saying it gives enough time for somebody
to get a damage tattoo
find a sick enough tattoo artist to
really like go deep like that you know
and
this idea of like the Joker martyring
himself could be super dark which Lobby
were saying this movie is extremely dark
and some people are talking about how
it's similar to the movie Network which
ends with someone on air in a massive
unplanned rant everyone's watching
online yeah he's not gonna take it
anymore and what if like super dark but
what if we see a suicide that launches
that's some critics are saying this
movie's irresponsible maybe that's what
they're referring to
Austrian producers are making smiley
faces
he looked rich
behind bars maybe into the estate right
so that could potentially Bruce Wayne
okay there's other parts in the trailer
that people have speculated that that is
the Wayne family okay okay wait I'm
gonna pause you then because I do want
to go into this so let's just like
clarify where we are so eric has said
that he believes that the Joker is going
to win the day he's going he is the hero
of the story so it would make sense that
he gets some sort of hero it's gonna
really like be in his mind it's more
could be revisionist history ones their
own protagonist this is rogue theory
here is that he's gonna die at the end
of the movie because he's just stupid
little weakling it's Chris's words not
mine I was freaked out when I first saw
it I legitimately was like wow this is
my trip and because it's so weak yeah
and so but he dies he wasn't himself
he's a Christ figure who dies who
inspires a Church of jokers yeah other
people take her take up the mantle and
and the the argument and maybe they live
on to fight a grown up Batman at some
point now going to your theory where
it's instead of those it's he he doesn't
die assume at the
and he lives on so he's that's 1981 this
older man yeah I think that there's
going to be some major interaction with
the Wayne family that's going to tie us
into a greater Batman universe and I
know a lot of people are speculating
that we see the Wayne family we could go
the route of the what I consider to be
view og Batman movies back in the day
where Joker kills the Wayne parents tim
burton's yes exactly
but I think let's flip it on its head
right so we see him interacting with a
kid who's probably Bruce we see Thomas
Wayne having strong opinions being a
very influential figure in that time and
maybe I'm influenced because I played a
lot of the tell-tale Batman videogames
but I'm like woo Thomas Wayne was up to
no good
what if Joker ends up killing Bruce and
Tate yep taking out the kid and then
Thomas Wayne becomes the Batman type
figure but then it also kind of ties in
with that idea of who's the real hero
here in this story if we've already
established that maybe Thomas is up to
no good and I think it sets us up for a
really interesting universe and a much I
mean it seems funny but they have darker
take on Gotham because Gotham is already
so dark but a real kind of Game of
Thrones a square everybody's got their
strengths and their weaknesses we don't
have a clear villain we don't have a
clear hero
so type of battleground and it's all
public perception maybe it's a little
the boys coming right but but I actually
think that the boys is more simplistic
than it has to be I like the boys but I
think that if you're you're connecting
to basically flashpoint version of
Batman exact slash point the flash goes
back changes just a small thing well not
to him but I changes something one of
the ramifications is that Bruce Wayne is
killed and Thomas Wayne becomes Batman
but he is a murderous Batman because he
lost a child right instead of being an
orphan he would his kid was killed in
front of him and so he's really kind of
bad but he's not evil he just way over
does all right he's like the Punisher
kind of sure and I like that version
being the one that could theoretically
be up against a black because then it is
complicated where neither is good
neither is bad if it's just straight up
you know Thomas Wayne is evil I think
one it's a it's just a bummer to see
like evil Batman but - I think it's like
it then it becomes too easy to know who
to root for no yeah I wouldn't I
wouldn't say make him go entirely evil
the complexity is where this but people
are saying you know if we do go the Tim
Burton route and Joker or Arthur flex
character in this film kills Thomas and
Martha then there's gonna be this huge
discrepancy between Joker and Batman
moving forward and I guess we could have
like a crusty old Joker fighting a young
Bruce Wayne but I like the idea of the
mean Thomas much better yeah Heath
Ledger Joker has always been kind of an
older character if you go back to Cesar
Romero was like 50 when he played yeah
so I mean and how old was Michael Keaton
yeah I don't remember thinking there was
an age gap between he was in his 40s and
I think he played so the Joker's except
for Heath Ledger he's always been played
by an older at yeah they don't need to
be contemporaries but I'll say that your
theory of you know maybe he kills the
kid I like they could align with a
theory that I've heard about where maybe
actually Arthur Fleck is an illegitimate
child of Thomas Waynes man's
half-brother and he's killed potentially
he's killed his brother right but
tragedy ya know you think like how old
is Joaquin Phoenix how old is Brett
Colin plays Thomas Wayne like Brett
Collins in his 60s
Joaquin Phoenix is in his 40s that could
happen especially if you think young
early like relationship culture Wow
that's cool so and that could actually
work with up with a lot of your guys's
theories right he dies he wins he lives
whatever it could still always be this
guy's son secretly which it was so great
because then it would really just
opposed with their social class standing
right where you just see like like you
know maybe it's the kind of thing where
the the mom is you know Thomas Waynes on
TV like giving a speech or
whatever and she kind of is like I don't
know if she would say that's your daddy
kind of thing I'm stealing that from
Armageddon play with the doctor toy
walking talk smash pops watch TV is like
you mentioned like Thomas Wayne a doctor
like what if like this movie is all
about like honestly health care
treatment for mental illness Arthur
Fleck loses his health care treatment
that's why his like health care person
has to drop them and as Thomas Wayne as
someone who's supposed to be healing the
sick of Gotham has abandoned this
illegitimate is the doctor and then he
pays the price for it yeah all right
these were all I'm pretty happy this
week these were these were actually
pretty rogue theories so some upper for
me and for the audience in just a few
words in a tweet your rogue theory of
how you think the Joker is gonna end and
what are launching okay The Joker
becomes crime king of Gotham in his own
imagination Joker's dead
the followers will rise Joker takes out
Bruce inspiring a way to overactive
Thomas Wayne Batman figure mmm nice I
mean I gotta give the rug for this week
to Tricia that's started an old man
series of kid death Papo revenge yeah I
just I just love two old men fighting to
the death
gadgets you know like supernatural
superhero powers all right guys we're
gonna jump into in a moment
oh by the way listen Oh in the comments
which of those you thought was the most
rogue theory but also which one you
think is the most likely to happen but
before we get into it chapter 2 just
real quick thank you that people to help
us bring this show to you new rockstars
ro theories brought to you by some very
nice sponsors Munez doesn't take
themselves too seriously and they think
that we shouldn't take underwear too
seriously
they believe undies should be soft fit
you perfectly and offer fun patterns
that give me the freedom to express
yourself they don't just have undies by
the way they also have super great
onesies and loungewear if they keep you
nice and comfortable as you rock back
and forth trying to push that waking
nightmare of it chapter 2 out of your
mind I personally really love the
high-tech fabric to me a disease is its
micro modal it's three times softer than
cotton so it's extremely comfortable to
wear just around the house in general
but specifically when I'm working out in
fact I actually can't bring myself to
wear any of mine on my undies underwear
anymore because it's so scratchy in
comparison that's totally true I'm
wearing it right now as I record this me
undies has a great deal for new rock
stars fans for any first-time purchasers
you get 15% off and free shipping so to
get your 15% off your first pair free
shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee
go to me undies comm slash rock stars
that's me undies dot-com slash rock
stars for 15% off your first pair and
free shipping all right back to it
alright guys and we're back and during
the break we had to separate Chris and
Eric they were in this intense brawl
apparently Chris was not is not into
this idea of being in his mind by Bob
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
okay so guys it chapter 2 is opening
this week I'm a big it fan actually and
I know a bunch of us have read the books
but I know you guys all so before we get
into what we want to theorize about it I
just want to like
establish baseline here some of you hate
the concept of like watching this movie
right oh yeah I can't do horror films
like I'm incapable I will not sleep and
read the book as a child I read the book
and I I will admit I only got so far in
before I like threw the book under my
bed and then like for the next I don't
know a couple weeks I had to run and
jump into my bed because I don't want my
feet anywhere near where I'd from under
my bed and pulled me under we all flowed
down here like I was like did this book
keep reappearing on your nightstand
every time you tried to throw it away
yeah no just her mom like tidying up
again I think I made the same mistake as
you were saying this earlier where I
also read it as a child because I
thought it was just like you know our
Alstyne kind of stuff and then they
torture animals and babies I was like oh
my god and I messed me up real good
messed me up so good to the point where
when the it movie came out years and
years and years and go and had everyone
yes and had jonathan brandis in it yeah
any girl my generation was like not even
his appearance in that film could get me
to watch that film saying something
maybe I was jgt though Chris you also I
was terrified with my first time because
I saw the miniseries as a kid yeah and I
was like it didn't really scare me as
well I mean you already 48 after being
jilted by Newhart you kind of went to
the cigarettes and every move you
anymore there's times I literally could
not like no more anxiety like this is
just too much I'm like I'm done I'm
gonna walk out cuz just it I had a lot
of scary movies don't really scare me
like that movie just found something
inside me that was very vulnerable much
like Arthur flex weakness
[Laughter]
especially at your age mine's all flared
up anyway guys there was a topic of
discussion here and it's about the
concept of it since we haven't seen it
yet or Eric actually got to see it mhm
Shane finally was it again into one of
those yeah but let's instead talk about
what might come after this we know the
story well enough to know that it
famously takes place in two timelines
right in the book it's 1958 in 1985 I
think but now it's been it's 20 years
later it's 80 in 2015 yeah now wish
basically I but and so those two
timelines are supposed to encapsulate
the entire story of it but just
wondering it's a huge huge hit is there
are there ways that they can take this
franchise and keep it alive or do they
have to stop at in Chapter two yeah
could could Pennywise become like the
new Annabelle right like he's every 27
years right so we could totally go
forward or backwards right well in the
books they they go into those stories a
little bit and what's really interesting
is every time the Pennywise the clown
shows up so it's it's 27 to 28 years so
he's a little range to start it off
there's some sort of insane massive
tragedy then there's a bunch of murders
and then to end it there's also some
sort of insane massive tragedy so it if
we did go back and tell those stories I
mean it's like an epoch every single
time he comes out it's a really epic yes
yeah the very fun book and then in the
books right or in the book or in the
movie as well they they should give hint
set these past things there was that
factory that exploded on an Easter egg
hunt a day there was
colored eggs there was a scene where
it's like a colonial family a woman had
to like sacrifice one of her kids to the
beasts to save the rest of her kid had
to turn away just as it was like they're
gonna do it for the movie and they they
ended up cutting it from the first film
yeah so this new thing like if they now
that they've changed the timeline to be
like 1988 so we're looking at like early
60s there could be another movie looking
at early 30s there could be another
movie around the night like for earlier
than that impression should be another
movie you could go in in any direction
right because future it was there
essentially before man was according to
the book at least it came from space or
something but it's it's there it's
prehistoric and then also it could be
post historic if they do what they did
so essentially why why it comes back 27
years later is they didn't finish the
job right they just hurt it very bad
they could just maybe have done that
again so then yeah we can jump 27 28
years in the future again and again and
again
get it 3,000 I'm down with that yeah I
mean there's something about the further
in history back that you go the scarier
things get because there's fewer things
that can save you
you know like movies were scarier before
people had cell phones movies were scary
before there was like the internet or
GPS or anything like that and you guys
see the witch it came out a couple years
ago the directors doing the new one the
lighthouse which kinda looks crazy with
Robert Pattinson Willem Dafoe but yeah
it takes place in colonial times see
people get banished from a colonial
colony and have to go live on a farm and
then yeah one of the daughters get
seduced by Satan and it's terrifying and
it's because it's so remote and so
removed from any semblance of society
that we know that makes it more
terrifying I just imagine what if leaves
swap out you know Lucifer from that
story for just Pennywise this entity
demonic presence reminder I mean what if
he's on a boat take off the tea drop the
tea it's cleaner
for those of you that's okay I don't
like any of our pictures so far but do
we think they're gonna do those are
gonna be in it Chapter three
I want her to be what exactly I gotta go
gotta go I'm gonna go to win a
three-meter movie theater scene
clutching my chest ruining a 16 year old
movie theater employees from The
Simpsons no I definitely think they're
gonna do in it chapter three I mean it
the money's there
the money's there people are loving it I
mean even you saying like you don't
normally get scared by films but if
they're making money and having immense
success with this they're gonna keep
making it can they do any spin-offs
because there are I mean well actually
of course they can the Stephen King
expanded universe right he's already
established all of his books are
connected through the The Dark Tower a
fair amount of his books turned movie
have not been done great we just saw Pet
Sematary early seer game dr. sleep which
is the sequel to just looks purgatory
was okay not too connected it didn't
need to be connected to the rest of the
universe other than you know things
resurrect and there's some kind of
cosmic evil that's at play here and then
yeah there was carry the the chloë grace
moretz reboot carry that key right i
still think they would start it off of
it right they would they would now make
a whole new universe I mean apparently
universes don't matter how long they
live what it connects you think to
Castlerock that series apparently has a
ton of Easter eggs to the Stephen King
universe in and just like his books
every book references dairy in some way
yeah yeah
I would love to see them actually do
Dark Tower well and use that to tie in
all of the different books and stories I
don't know if anyone read The Dark Tower
books but it goes pretty deep into its
own Stephen King because it's very
bizarre to hear him talk about himself
like that but he does and so it could
work yeah this is a lot of drugs but it
also fee it feels very much like I made
some real weird choices and you know
what I'm doubling down yeah and I'm
gonna explain how this kind of makes
sense or he made one weird choice to
start using a lot of cocaine in the 80s
and that influenced everything else how
about questions these are questions out
of our ope off screen producers ask and
we have no idea what they say or what a
good answer will sound like but we'll
try alright let's go for it all right
today is Bey day because it's Beyonce's
birthday mmm what a nerdy topic what
role would you like to see Beyonce play
in the MCU just Beyonce a character in
the MCU Chris copes wife yes
like who's Chris cope doesn't matter
doesn't matter she-hulk that's cool yeah
but that's like gonna be everybody's
go-to what his what she-hulk immediately
I see sorry I say that fella because my
first thought was also storm and then I
was like no I don't wanna pick storm
though then you said she I was like oh
that's better
yeah yeah Beyonce is Mark Ruffalo's
cousin yeah alright NASA is
investigating the first crime committed
in space aboard the International Space
Station I feel like that's like a
Nicholas Cage movie already
what's the spacey Asst crime you could
commit speeding at the speed of light oh
oh it's a crime against nature
spying on people from Earth from the
space station like using like satellite
view let me think that's why they're I
mean that's why
I can't leave I'm not gonna hang above
the earth me leer I don't mean random
leering IRA mean like oh this was my
nemesis from high school and like
messing with their devices instantly I
know
did they give you access to what are we
talking about Space Station yeah I
thought that was the whole point is that
we verifications that would get an
annoying very quickly yeah moon litter
two words moon litter there's so much
litter on that moon they're freeze-dried
food so much litter on the moon and yeah
that's the crime you would commit we
need to solve that in the real world
before we start making movies about you
invented your own question that you
answered there Robert Pattinson said
this week that when he tried on the bat
suit it took five people to help him and
they had to squeeze his butt cheeks that
I'm gonna say that's out of context of
whether or not that helped him get in
the costume is just by people line up
who wins and why Captain America's butt
or Batman's butt Oh Captain America's
but America's its CGI yeah is this the
new like DC versus Marvel debate
America's ass it's not even a question
it also depends on which Batman right
cuz bat flex bud is probably just that
like wide but that like hangs off the
sides of a toy but like Captain
America's butt is like the finest most
perfectly sculpted but in the universe
so I don't think any of the Batman's
we've seen could even come close I think
we should come be be comparing tanis's
ass to Darkseid's ass the off-screen
producers are nodding like we got the
answer right for the first time in the
series of the show guys Krispy Kreme has
a new pumpkin spice cheesecake filled
donut I saw that ice cheesecake filled
donut at Krispy Kreme
look amazing looks disgusting if shitty
food would never eat that really nice
cake cream filling just not the pie
anything we could melt up that is gross
I mean a lady that was formerly pregnant
I think it sounds amazing
well we all can claim that guys Austrian
producer worked really hard on this
question so we're gonna read it all
right okay Andy we got you
if pumpkin spice were a superpower
really hard would it be used for good or
evil evil calories poison what even is
that superpower to change the solution I
can think is like powdered toast man
from runnin sippy except for pumpkin man
hey powdered toast man's ass for Kevin
America's ass that's a tougher yeah he
was definitely Hispanic guys this week
that's it thank you so much to Eric Foss
to Chris cope and to Trisha Hershberger
real quick work and when we find you
guys you can find me at that girl Trish
with no I in the girl on Facebook
Twitter and Instagram and at Trisha
Hershberger on YouTube and twitch cool
to girls no eyes Chris cope we're gonna
find you
everything's at Chris cope comedy
Twitter Instagram website sweet all
right and also look up this guy's a
stand-up bits are very funny and Eric
Foss when will you return to me I'll be
back on the channel live this week to do
some it videos it chapter 2 there's you
know Indian explained there's a lot of
weird stuff for this movie haven't seen
it that require explanation a lot of
like weird little Easter eggs and cameos
too great alright alright that's not
what my question meant but we'll talk
later
guys thank you so much this is really
fun what's the most Road make sure to
subscribe to the podcast you get it
before the videos and follow us at new
rock stars follow me at Philip Molina on
Twitter and Instagram and cheers Chris
cope you survived the episode
[Applause]
[Music]